good evening and welcome to this
district planning meeting uh malden
district council today third of march
2022 i'm councillor mark hurd chairman
of this committee
i'd like to welcome new councillor simon
morgan
already a week into his term
he is
he is the conservative member for
wickham bishops and wooden ward i
congratulate him on his campaign
and welcome him to the district with the
departure of one councillor and the
arrival of a new member i hope to draw a
line under the past
and look to the future of this
hard-working authority its officers and
current members
um in in view of your comments can i
commend the way that you have um
acted over the last
year 18 months
thank you very much and actually i offer
my congratulations to the very very
difficult circumstances that the staff
are that to operate um under this so
i do welcome a new start well done to
them
so members uh this meeting will be
streamed live and recorded and by being
present in this meeting you are given
consent to being recorded this recording
will also appear on the council's
website
um during each item please indicate if
you wish to speak and i will then invite
you to do so at the appropriate time as
always i encourage members to keep
contributions clear and concise
and when invited to speak please remain
seated
and speak clearly
referring to the agenda papers
and ensure that you reference a page or
paragraph the fire exits are marked by
the green signs and obviously be aware
of the differing law levels
so
members uh
we'll move on to
agenda item two apologies for absence do
we have any apologies please tara
thank you chairman yes apologies have
been received from councillor bill
councillor schemes councillor siddal and
councillor mrs stilts thank you
thank you very much
yes i think that's councillor brianville
yep
agenda item
thank you agenda item three declarations
of interest members are reminded that
they are required to declare any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests which they know they might
have in items of business on the agenda
having regards to paragraph six to
of the code of conduct for members they
are reminded that they need to repeat
their declarations at the appropriate
point
in the meeting and leave the room if
required under the code of conduct
unforeseen interests must be declared
similarly
at the appropriate time do i have any
interests please counsellor durham
chairman thank you i have a non-cunery
interest as a member of essex county
council of the statutory council to ease
your night matters of planning thank you
thank you for that councillor fleming
thank you chairman uh a non-pecuniary as
a member of essex county council here
statutory consultees thank you thank you
and councillor stamp uh yes thank you
chairman a member of essex county
council non-pecuniary exactly what the
other two councillors have said
thank you very much any other
declarations members
nope okay we'll move on to agenda item
four minutes of the previous meeting
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting of the district planning meeting
held on the 19th of january are approved
as a true and accurate record uh they're
presented for accuracy only and i so
moved do i have a seconder councillor
maze thank you
any member wish to speak on any matter
of accuracy
can these be agreed by assent
thank you very much indeed
we move on
we move on to agenda item five
uh 21
00961
reserved
pages nine to forty six
um the officer presenting the report uh
is miss anna testoglou
could you present the report base
thank you
thank you to you chairman
so the
the application uh relates to
let me just
relates to the largest of the three
sites allocated for development in the
north haywards garden suburb referred to
in policy s2 as s2d
north hebrew site which was planted
planning concern for a hybrid mixed-use
development on appeal on the 25th of
october 2019 under the terms of
application
15.00419 slash out
the current proposal relates to phase 2
of the proposed development and in
particular the land that is necessary to
provide the strategic landscaping and
infrastructure elements such as roads
paths open space and sustainable
drainage system features
for this phase
this application site is split into two
parts the largest part
is located to the north and north east
of hebrews wood which is here
and the smaller part is to the southwest
of hebrews wood
it should be noted
that the details of the relief road
which runs along the northern part
of the application site do not form
parts of the assessment of the current
resident reserve matters application as
these were granted detailed concerns as
part of the hybrid application
um it should be noted that a revised
strategy phasing plan was approved on
the 14th of january under the terms of
application 21
slash
05187 slash dt the main
the main revision to the previously
approved strategic phasing plan was the
inclusion of parcel 10
which is here
and
an area to the north of the
local center
which is down here
this application covers the strategic
landscaping for phase two an application
pertaining the strategic um landscaping
and infrastructure elements of phase one
which is the blue
and was previously approved uh under the
terms of application 21 0 0 384 slash
res by the district planning committee
on
30th of september 2021
the key elements of the strategic
landscaping and infrastructure covered
in this submission
are the surrounding
the landscaping surroundings of the
eastern section of the relief road and
broad street green roundabout
the internal spine road
which is here
and the crane corridors surrounding
parcels 10
11 and 12.
the second phase of the acoustic barrier
which runs along the relief road on the
northern part of the application site
the local equipped area which is to the
south of parcel 12
and the
pumping station all also to the south of
parcel 12.
the internal road
associated to an associate attenuation
basins to the north of parcel 8.
any pedestrian and cycle links within
the site and also the proposed bus stops
which are to the south of parcel 10.
the hybrid planning application contains
a number of conditions requiring either
the adherence of matters agreed as part
of the outline permission or the
submission of further details to be
agreed either as part of a very safe
month's application or at the start of
condition application
this application also seeks permission
for the details required by conditions
18 in relation to works to trees and
hedgerows condition 19 in relation to
details of the acoustic barrier
condition 27 in relation to the details
of bus stops condition 28 in relation to
the details of pedestrian and cycle
routes condition 31 in relation to the
overall landscape strategy but not the
details of the landscape design and
specifications which is part two of this
condition and condition 32 in relation
to
refuse and recycling
so as part of the application a number
of technical plans have been submitted
including the landscape proposal these
are closer views of
what i've showed you earlier
um
proposed illustrative sections
that show
the band treatment and some
attenuation basins
sections of the basins
sections of the band
i'm skipping through those quite quickly
we can come back to them later if you
want
um
some
general arrangements in relation to the
noise band which include the widths of
the band
along its length
the proposed
contours and levels of the noise band
which include the heights
of the band
the
longitudinal sections
of the band
uh some plants in relation to the
widening of some pitches in between the
parcels and around the hebrew sweet
and then some
vehicle technical
plans including swept analysis swept
path analysis for
articulated vehicles
for buses
for refuse vehicles
uh general arrangements of the highway
again this is the spine road and the
secondary road not the relief road this
was approved as part of the outline
permission
support levels
surface and carbine arrangement of the
roads proposed within the sites
highway contour plans
the proposal also includes some mammal
crossing tunnels underneath the
spine road
and the relief road this is to allow
access of
mammals from the countryside which is to
the north of the side to haybirdswood
these are the plants and elevations of
the pumping station
the bus stops
this is a detailed plan of the local
equipped area of play
and i have also included some
photographs
of the site
so these are
views from broad street green road this
is the s2f side to the south of the
application site
this is again from broad street green
towards the south
and towards the
east this is heybridge wood
and some photographs of the
surrounding area
so the principle of development of this
site has been accepted as part um as it
forms part of the north hebrew its
current suburb and part of the approved
hybrid application the strategic
landscaping and infrastructure proposed
for phase two
um
is compliant with the north hebrew
strategic master plan framework the
north hebrew city strategic design code
the approved design parameter plans and
the outline planning permission to which
it relates
it is considered that this second
section second phase policies of the
strategic landscaping
um sets out high
well-designed a well-designed framework
of green spaces and linkages that will
ensure that the development as a whole
delivers the high quality vibrant and
distinctive neighbors that the council
has in visits for the garden suburbs it
is also considered that the proposal
would be acceptable in terms of impact
on nearby headaches assets and the
quality of life of existing and future
occupiers
of the site following minor amendments
the development would be acceptable in
terms of its impacts on the highway
network and highway safety and
objections raised from the highway
authority
the proposed surface water features
comply with the approved parameter plans
and the overall great
drainage strategy
as approved as part of the outline
permission all technical details in
relation to the surface water training
scheme are to be dealt with through
condition and not as part of this
reserved maths application
a number of ecological mitigation and
enhancement measures have been
considered and are and are secured
through the imposition of a condition to
ensure that habitats and biodiversity
are protected and enhanced
the development is supported by an
agricultural impact assessment which
confirms that the application enables
this application enables the retention
of a number of trees that they were
originally proposed to be removed
so on the basis of the above offices
recommend approval of the application
subject to conditions on pages 42 to 45
of the agenda
i apologize for the lengthy presentation
thank you very much indeed
we have one public participant for this
planning application in line with the
public participation scheme i will now
invite the agent from countryside
properties limited mr kevin coleman to
read out his submission
do please sir
thank you
okay um
so mr coleman may i remind you that you
are allocated two minutes only for
public speaking in accordance with this
scheme
thank you very much
well thank you and and once again thank
you for the opportunity to speak
um uh as has just been a
presented by the officer you'll be aware
that this is our second
strategic infrastructure reserve matters
relating primarily to the north
eastern part of the site
the similar application that we made for
the western part of the site as you've
heard was approved in september last
year
so the key features of this application
as as we see are the attractive
landscape entrance into the site from
broad street green road
the tree-lined spine road that extends
into the site from broad street green
road
the remainder of the landscaping to the
approved relief road which includes the
extensive hedgerow planting
along the north side of that as well as
the the landscape fund on the south side
the application includes new children's
play space
as well as all of the pedestrian and
cycle links that you'd expect
and this application includes the
the buffer around haybridge wood
which is designed to protect protect the
woodland
overall it includes extensive nutrient
hedgerow planting and you've just heard
the officer mentioned that the
arboricultural report that's in with the
application
does identify several trees previously
identified for removal that we're now
able to retain
so overall um the landscaping the roads
the pedestrian and cycle links uh are
all in accordance with the outline
planning permission and with the design
code again as the officers just
mentioned so i feel like i'm repeating a
lot of what's just been said which i
apologize
and for those reasons we hope that the
committee will be able to support the
application tonight thank you very much
okay thank you very much indeed
so members i'll open the debate and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments that you wish on the report
councillor durham first yeah thank you
thank you very much chairman
it's very good to see this application
come before us and it's actually very
pleasing to see that it's largely in
accordance with the
garden suburb design brief that we were
given several years ago
and i don't have a problem with it but
we're getting these
these reserved mata applications in
piecemeal
and for reasons of our five-year land
supply
it really is in the interest of this
authority that the build-out of this
site and others happens as soon as
possible
so when are we likely to get the reserve
matter applications
for detailed design and other layouts
and you know i remind members of the
provision of the community facilities
that are part of this application are
based on the completion and occupation
of the homes
and therefore it honestly can't come
soon enough so i would much rather see
this get moving rather than having these
individual reserve matter applications
come to us
once every couple of months thank you
thank you
are you able to answer that uh when we
receive these
through you ceremony the only thing i
can say is that an application for the
reserve matters residential element has
been submitted and is currently under
consideration
thank you very much councillor white
next um thank you mr chairman um
actually i'm very disappointed in this
application and i'm a bit surprised it's
come before us and i'm not in agreement
with um
the previous speaker
because is there a policy on bridal ways
and new developments in the malden
district because i was aware that there
was
and
every single application we raised this
and there's not a single part there is a
mention of a broadway somewhere in the
paperwork but it doesn't say where it's
going to go or what it's going to be and
this is one of our policies that the
council has decided this isn't just
something we've done overnight we raised
it at the last application and we were
sure that we were told officers were
going to address it so where are they
thank you
anna can you help there please bridal
wise
yeah three chairman this should have
been part of the outline permission the
um the provision of bridal ways
and as far as i'm aware there was no
condition imposed by the inspector
assess the application
right but it's not the point because
this is one of our policies that we have
as part of granting and it should be a
reason why
it should wait until they're in there
and the developers should show a little
bit of goodwill as far as i'm concerned
in putting these in they know our
policies and and for everybody to
completely disregard them
is just unfair mr lee
thank you chairman um
planning permission
when it's you know it's granted by the
council and traditionally enough in a
full which is the one permission um
applications such as this are done in
two phases through the outline
commission the reserve matters but it is
one permission um
case law is clear guidance is clear
legislation's clear about certain things
need to be required at outline stage and
then
reserve matters in future will fill them
in for better phrases um and as mr
chuglu said you know there was no
requirement by the inspector for vital
ways to be delivered
as part of this development and it was
through the outline stage is where the
council needed to raise that concern and
require it whether or not you agree with
the fact that they are not quite away
the fact you agree with other points or
don't agree with
it's essence becomes a moot point
because this has been accepted as a
principle and it's not in the eyes of
the planning system appropriate to raise
matters such as this at the time of the
reserve matters
it's not about personal opinion it's not
about what policies we may adopted later
we have to look at what the inspector
granted in 2019 and the restrictions and
limitations that were put on it and in
flip side the the freedom that was put
on it and there is no requirement for
part of this application statistical
same through conditions to require a
broad away and any objection to that i
think would be very difficult to
sustain thank you all right thank you if
i'm like just trying to move let's move
on because i've got you've asked two
questions cancer what counseling
uh yes thank you chairman um the uh the
summary proposal on page nine
uh although it mentions conditions it
makes no mention of condition eight
but condition eight appears elsewhere in
the paperwork and if i've read the rest
of the paperwork correctly it seems to
suggest that the archaeological
condition has already been discharged
and that the
work that's being proposed through the
reserve matters will not impact
on the archaeology of the site could i
have confirmation that that is correct
please
yes mr cheshire thank you for
determining yes that's that's correct
these these um the archaeological um
elements have been discharged by a
condition
and yes they have been dealt with
thank you for the explanation so so the
work that's being proposed here the
reserve matters will have no further
archaeological impact
through your ceremony yes that was all
assessed and
i mean all
whatever was whatever works had to be
done any excavation works in relation to
archaeology have been done and have been
uh dealt with so this this scheme will
not um will not go beyond what was
approved under the outline permission
where this condition was imposed
so it won't it won't extend beyond the
um the application side the of the
hybrid application so no further no
further archaeological
assessment would be required
okay thank you thank you council channel
thank you chairman very much
um page 44 where we get onto the
conditions condition four and five
i'm sorry chairman but they look to me
as though they're the same condition
regarding the leap
i've looked at it and i can't see any
differentiation in the wording so it
looks like there's been a duplication
then then my question is if we have a
duplication of conditions regarding the
leap
what condition may have been left off
and regarding the leap uh in fact i'm
now moved to page 25
and i'm looking at um 5.2.42
it seems a pumping station is going to
be located in close proximity to the
leap
the report is not clear on the detail of
how close this structure is to leap but
it makes it quite clear that this is not
ideal that the structure will be located
there in such close proximity to the
area of play
and it mentions going to be enclosed by
a high brick wall
and on balance it seems to be that this
is being seen to be reasonable could i
perhaps see or be given information as
to regarding the distance
of the pumping station from the
perimeter of the leak
and how high is the brick wall we're
talking about and have we got any um
have we got any indication or design
within the plan submitted
to see um what this might look like on
the ground
thank you
thank you chairman thank you miss
cheshire glue yeah through youtube um i
apologize for the duplication first of
all of the of the condition there was no
condition um further condition to be
added or missed
from the duplication
um
in relation to the pumping station uh
there is a 15 meter
gap between the
the pumping station and any
residential element
and in particular to the loop i can i
can have a look and come back to you in
that
further question then please
should a condition be on this um
approval then regarding the pumping
station and the brick rule referred to
because it does make reference to it and
that's what i thought might be the
missing condition i'm not saying it
should be but i wondered if it was
surrounding the pumping station and the
brick wall that's going to be applied to
i presume have a safety expect regarding
the closeness to the leap
through you chairman
there is a condition condition one that
includes all the plants includes the
plants that they make refer the
elevation plants of the pumping station
of the 1.8 meter high wall around the
pumping station which i've shown you
earlier in the presentation so he is
conditioned to be installed
erected so
okay and that's enough is it
the chairman obviously due to the
replication the same
condition uh would advise if members do
grant permission i'll see we remove the
uh duplicate condition thank you
okay thank you councillor councillor
hull
thank you um
i'm too really disappointed there's no
bridal ways put in here and how in the
future are we going to be able to um
rectify this because even when they are
put in the planning commission that we
don't
they don't
materialize
well i think i think that question has
been answered about bridal ways and it's
not about this application so
do you have any other question
i just don't understand why it's always
they're just always left out and it
should have been
part of the planning okay mr lee
see you chairman um
as i said you know this was something
that should have been dealt with that
outline you know unfortunately it wasn't
um
we revisit it at the various phases of
the same application but you're going to
be getting the same argument in relation
to the 2019.
on the outline it definitely was because
we both brought it up we definitely
brought it up
but it's the remembering that the 2000
and this is the out this is the appeal
decision based from the 2015 application
not the
decision that officers recommended for
approval members granted in 2019 the
inspector didn't put a condition on in
relation to bridalways therefore as you
know that's been taken away from us and
how many frustrated of members may feel
officers may feel the public may feel
whatever we are tied by what the
inspector imposed as on the appeal
decision and said you know you remember
you're right you do bring it up on every
application but you're going to hear the
same thing from officers unfortunately
we could be members please one at a time
please the question has been answered
councillor edwards
thank you chairman
as board member i have three questions
if i may although it does say great
cotton parish but
hey bridge
um
firstly in 3.18
it's
13 he's 13.
3.18 is to um this current application
is seeks to discharge the details of
condition 18
of the original application 419.
the condition 18 is the removal of trees
can i just have clarification
that this seizes there's no more trees
to be
dislodged or taken out just to confirm
it going to discharge that condition
yeah three determine first of all is the
discharge of condition in relation to
this phase of the development not the
whole site first of all
and
as i said the updated agricultural
report that's been submitted with this
application to revise the one that was
approved as part of the outline
application confirms that not only
there's going to be
no fair the loss of trees but there are
i think
seven of them that they were originally
proposed to be removed and they are now
proposed to be retained
can i come back on um
condition 18 no trees or headphones
within the site that's the whole site
will be failed
three point one eight this current is
their magic application six to discharge
the details in condition 18. so that's
the whole site
oh i've read that wrong
see chairman this is a phased
application so this application relates
to the area that is spread as part of
this application rather than the entire
site um
sorry chairman the condition 18 in the
original uh uh approved uh removal
is no trees
or hedgerows will be
doubled back and you're trying now to
discharge that condition but it applies
to the whole site
yes yes
when you
when when you read the uh within the
report at the end of the paragraph that
i'm referring to condition 18 i say that
the current reserve mattress application
seeks to discharge the details of
condition 18 in relation to phase 2.
at this stage of condition application
was was
determined in relation to phase one as
well so we have discharged this
condition and really as a again this
application is to be determined in
different phases like there are five
different phases so for each phase
there's going to be at this partial
discharge of of some conditions such as
condition 18. so it does not relate the
whole side is in relation to
phase two only okay thank you can i
next question yes next question um
playground equipment can i ask
who is maintaining that from not just
from a repair point of view or from a
health and safety
in terms of playground equipment has to
have
a certification
through your ceremony that would have
been part of the section six a great as
part of the outline permission for all
leaps within the site
and maintenance and management of the
leaps would have been part of that
not as part of the condition
yes chairman about but who's actually
going to i was just going to say is that
who's going to maintain their properties
the chairman of the cuff officers won't
have that information it wouldn't be
material consideration for the
termination this application anyway
because it's a requirement through the
section 106 for the outline statement
the requirement is to provide it
yeah okay and finally uh chairman um for
the chair
um
cycle links
from the relief road into broad street
green
where are they actually going to hit
broad street green bearing in mind broad
street green does not have cycle lanes
yes please through your tournament uh
we can only
we can only determine what's within the
red line of the application
there is part of broad street green that
is included within the application site
and there are works to be done in these
parts of broad street green road
and i mean whatever is
beyond that is is outside the
application side so where would cycle
links link up to
to
with the rest of haybridge
just to leave the chairman um
as mrs douglas said we can only worry
about the application site and we have
facilitated the potential for that
within the site there is the
permeability through cycles
whether or not
there's a connection outside of that
isn't really a consideration for this
application this application can only
worry about itself washing its own face
and hopefully try and provide something
that adds betterment to the area
but not even if you can't unfortunately
maybe facilitate anything outside of
that thank you
okay thank you thank you councillor
yeah thank you chair um i've got a
couple of questions in a comment it's
not surprisingly um for the the noise
bangs um that we're going to be put in
and i see that the size of the trees
that are on top of the band do they form
part of the acoustic curtain
through determine the the acoustic
barrier would be the band and
an acoustic fence but the details of the
landscaping does not form part of the
noise attenuation
but also the details of that are not to
be approved as part of this permission
of this application
yeah i was just a bit worried because
i'd hope that they'd plant the mature
trees that they are with the four people
who are going to live here on this
schematic that i'm looking at rather
than the little tiddly ones that are
going to take generations to grow
because that's something that we need
for for sound and carbon the second one
is um
it does link a little bit to the bridal
ways yeah and i have a slight area of
disappointment and i'm sure mr lee will
take great pleasure in shooting me down
in flames and that's fine
but we've got professional officers
and why didn't get raised earlier on
because you know how passionate certain
members are about these types of things
and we should think about the things
that are important for the members that
represent the communities and that we
should bring those forward it's not for
us to do that it's for us to to debate
it here and you can say it's not that
the planning inspector didn't think of
that that's great my point is let's
think about all of these things because
as i'm sitting here and i don't mean to
sound flippant because this has been
decided i know this is being built out
and you know that these massive estates
however you want to dress them up as um
i don't think they're the solution to
the problem long term
but at the moment i can just see
somebody cycling around there on a push
bike and if you want to ride your horse
you can go through there but you can't
go anywhere else
yesterday for you chairman um
i'd never take joints shooting a member
down firstly and i hope remember
but what i would say is that um
unless it sounds like i'm washing my
hands and i don't mean to be but these
schemes didn't sit under me in 2015. and
i honestly can't comment on that because
i wasn't i was i went to the council but
they sat under the planning policy team
the strategic applications did at the
time i had no involvement really in any
of these and i honestly have no input or
knowledge on the topic and to be honest
none of the officers that were there
then here now so i honestly can't
comment on that unfortunately thanks
okay council fleming next
thank you chair um turning to page 29 um
5.6.3
it refers to
rainwater butts permeable paving to
private driveways
given that this is a critical drainage
area how do we ensure that in five years
time all of those driveways haven't been
paved over
do you know if the developer has plans
to sort of covenant put covenants on the
development thank you
i heard the page but i didn't get the
paragraph
um
whatever has been submitted as part of
the
sustainable drainage strategy as part of
this application or any previous
application or any future application is
being conditioned through
its application that is being determined
so like for this one all of the um
supportive information that it has been
submitted with the application have been
conditioned so the application will have
to comply with them
and
the planning system does not control
anything that goes beyond the condition
so any covenants
are not a material planning
consideration
yeah but you would exactly yeah you
would you you would required
you would require these elements to be
maintained in perpetuity as you would
for like attenuation basis and other
drainage syst features okay let's come
back on that thank you chair um could we
put an informative on just something
about uh asking the developer to to
covenant because i know a lot of
developers are very strict on their
schemes
you have to have you know in some
developments doors or certain colors
because you know you do see it in new
developments even around malden
where originally it was a permeable
structure and then
down the line it's paved over and then
you get into surface water drainage
issues so that i think that would be
beneficial thank you
okay yes we've got that thank you can't
um counselor bill
i'm sure the officer is definitely not
old enough remember death rates
they come to a dead end what is the
going rate for motor boat risks been
over the cyclists
there's no point in having cycle rating
they're just going to stop at the
boundary
well i i don't see
plans
right
i think i think the first thing is i
don't think we can go beyond the bounds
of the site to start with um hedgehog
tunnels and uh yes
they are present yes
yes
okay counselor
yes
are we allowed to ask the developers
seeing as one's actually sitting here
now hey paris castle has asked could we
bring forward
the allocation of the
uh allotments
so that money would give up the buffer
between hayward way and the new house
being built
plus it means that the actual
allotments would be
established
okay well perhaps we'll answer that is
it possible to to do that it's chester
ugly yeah three determined i mean the
the allotments are not part of this
current application they're outside the
application side the current application
side they form part of the subsequent
the allotments are well
yeah here this is this is
yeah
i think that's outside this application
yeah
okay be on the red line councillor swain
oh thank you uh chairman a couple of
things one concerns the
um the ring road and then noise from it
and i understand that on the
inner side there is um
fencing and
um green barrier and all this sort of
thing um
but
presumably this road is above
the normal of the surrounding ground
area and i wonder where whether there's
much um
uh which we say much there to stop the
noise of the ring road going out into
the countryside beyond
which you need a noise barrier on the
outside of the road as well as
um
attenuation on the inside
um
particularly if the road is is above the
normal level
but my second point is on subs
and we know of the
concern about um excess water um going
off a site in in haybridge
um
i assume that the county council's flood
people will uh have assessed the
um
which we say the capacity of the suds on
this site to do what they're supposed to
do um but my my question further
question is
um when
the assessment of subs is made by the
developer or by the essex flood people
do they make an estimate of how long on
average during a year those areas are
going to be unusable
for other purposes
i mean they're usually
projected as being part of the green
space or recreational area um but that's
of no use if they are soggy for half the
half of the year
okay well do you want to answer the
first part yeah see you chairman um this
current application doesn't relate to
the ring road that was already granted
permission at outline stage so that
matters already been attacked by the
inspector and not for consideration as
part of this application in relation to
the suds point um it
it's a bit of a question about how long
is a piece of string because you know
quite often actually while they may be
put forward as part of the green
infrastructure etc unusual places
actually when we look at the
demand and the requirements of a site in
an area as officers and as local
authority we don't include that we look
at what is needed for its standalone and
we would discount that and at times we
do include them when there is evidence
that that would be quite minimal but
generally
no because it's not it's like a
betterment of having this green space
rather than actually being a requirement
i think i think the question was is
there an estimate about the unusability
of it or not that was the question it's
not necessarily no future we haven't got
that because it meets its requirement
for public open space without that so
it's a betterment of space rather than a
necessity picture okay
thank you council stamp
yes thank you chairman um could i ask
whose responsibility it is to actually
go on site and sign off these conditions
and i'll back that up with something
that's happening in one of the sites in
burnham on crouch it's all well and good
sitting here and saying we're going to
plant all these lovely trees and they're
going to be here but if you plant them
at the wrong time of the year and you
don't water them they die
it states quite clearly before mr lee
comes in and says it's a condition it
has to be replaced except i understand
all that i can read and i understand all
that i want to know who is actually
going to go out if this authority has
got the um staffing to be able to go out
and check these conditions and who goes
out and signs it all off in the end
because what we're experiencing finding
out is that the planting that should
have been planted throughout the scheme
suddenly appears to be 20 000 trees
going on in six weeks or a month so i
wouldn't like this to happen in any of
any other sites that are you know coming
to fruition now
and then obviously it then
and it's going to go to an enforcement
and rather than things to go to
enforcement it'd be better if this
authority has the manpower to go and
check check them off and sign the
conditions off properly and i'm going to
go back to the suds
exactly what mr lee says we've got the
same thing it was agreed this beautiful
three-tier suds well now we'll ended up
with a pond that's full of rubbish and
absolutely disgrace so who is monitoring
when these sites are being built out
before the end thank you thank you
chairman i know it's not relevant to
this but it's relevant to all of these
sites
mr lee i would appreciate an answer um i
know you could you'll save money the
answer is no one we don't have a
monitoring officer we if we receive a
complaint about enforcement we discharge
the conditions
if that's submitted as required fire
depends on you know prior
instrumentation if we receive a
complaint they'll be investigated but
just like most authorities i know we do
not have a monitoring officer in
relation to
the
process of conditions and how they come
forward um unfortunately that is the
count's decision but i don't think it's
really a debate for this application but
that is the situation accounts was in
relation to resources thank you chairman
i i didn't really expect to debate
through chair um but it actually
highlights the the issues that we're all
gonna these big sites are being
built out now yeah and look at the mess
we're gonna be in there was supposed to
be high quality sold through the ldp
there were high quality sites and
they're not materializing like that and
that's reflecting on this district and
if we have policies like what the bridal
ways was they should have been put in
and they shouldn't be missed and it
shouldn't just be putting down you know
to somebody else's responsibility thank
you
thank you i think uh that it's something
that you may want to raise at your your
local planning meetings lord you raised
it don't worry thank you all right thank
you
um
councillor
uh edwards and then i'll come back to
councillor bill
thank you chairman uh it's not a
question um
it's uh
i still have a major concern with
traffic uh road um
construction traffic
coming out onto broad street green as on
mobile road we had discussed last time
but i do see that there's world washes
and etc being put in
but construction traffic is still going
to come through here is it and that's my
concern thank you
okay council appeal
what i'm really really worried about is
the fact that the developer is actually
considering
well working on two
of the three roads that come in and out
of david on that side of cambridge
normally if you brought your green
shutoff then you'd use maple road
made by road shop for whatever reason
you'd go to broadspeed green at least
you've got an access
can we put in a condition that the
developers actually work
one at a time so that once they're clear
of the
main road
and then it's fenced off or whatever
they can carry on with the eternal work
but then start
on the other one so that the beast we're
not going to have two out of three votes
blocked because it hasn't been that nice
okay
i i i suspect this may be a highways
matter but uh
are we able to answer that please yeah
through you chairman yeah that that
cannot be controlled under this this
application we've determined the the
district committee to determine the
application in relation to the
construction access points a few months
ago and they've approved
the application that was that that
included
a construction access point onto broad
street green roads and a construction
access point onto maple road
and they do have a life for two maximum
of two years so you can't
said you know the district committee
approved that a couple of months ago
that isn't part of this consideration if
members wish to discuss that that should
have been brought up at the time this
application is specifically for these
not for the accesses through
construction thank you chairman
right um
thanks members please
counselor fluker
yeah thank you chairman um i just really
want to just drill into the construction
phase and i think anybody that's driven
past any of the major sites in the
district over the last couple of days
will probably join me in querying the
state of the roads um
it always concerns me chairman when we
have these multi-layered applications
although you know i do take comfort in
the fact that the reserve matters
application is in
um but i wanted to go to condition one
um
the report mentions wheel washing
but it
under condition one it does mention the
construction environmental
management plan which i would expect to
see it there and it also doesn't mention
any of the decision notices or the
previous applications although these are
mentioned in the report
so with the thing that i've mentioned
before chairman is is the conditions of
the road and the requirement of the uh
the developers to keep the roads clear
of mud and debris and detritus
now we speak to wheel washing but we
don't talk to this so gemini
you know if it's wrapped up in this
somewhere and it can be enforced i'm
happy but knowing what's gone on in the
past with these multi-layered
applications chairman during this phase
of the scheme i would like to see a
condition that actually covers
the cleaning of the road throughout the
construction phase because you've got
three entrances to this site
and the weather in the last couple of
days has highlighted what can happen
so chairman i would i would propose that
normally at this i can't see mr coleman
sitting in the corner but hopefully he's
nodding his head over there in agreement
with me but i would like to see
something in there chairman quite
clearly as a condition that 100 meters
either side of these entrances are kept
clean for this phase otherwise i fear
chairman that whilst the work's been
carried out for this phase they won't do
it but they will for the general
construction phase
did you get that channel i'm sure you
could summarize that yes i was uh i was
writing it down yes
so uh who who's going to answer this mr
glue yeah thank you
so the question is can we put a
conditioning yeah through you chairman
we have already determined as i said
earlier we have already determined the
application for the construction access
points there is no proposal for
construction access point as part of
this this reserve matters application
when we've considered the two
construction access points i think it
was a couple of months ago we have
imposed a condition in relation to will
washing facilities and
and
and other
required um precautions not to have an
impact onto the existing highway network
um
there is also a condition that has been
discharged in relation to construction
and traffic and construction management
and and this is part of the start of
concept application that we have already
determined
so this is not
an application
that we would be able to impose such
condition because it doesn't
involve construction access points
if i could just come back based on what
miss tascallos just said
this this committee agreed quite clearly
and we spoke of 100 meters either side
of these entrance points as a condition
they would be kept clear of mud debris
and detritus i remember this word
detritus
and we agreed that
now
perhaps mrs tasclew could confirm
whether or not that actual condition is
in there because i don't think she did
so if it's if it's dropped off then i'm
afraid we've got to sit
here yeah through you chairman i'm
referring to planning application
21.00788
which was which related to
the construction access points and yeah
following the um
following the debate here an additional
condition was imposed in that respect
yeah it yeah it's not a spot it's not
part of this application again
but i think the clarity i'm looking for
germany is to make sure that that
condition is in there and if it's not i
still think we can add it to this
because it's still relying on those
entrances but you know chairman i'll
happily give way to anybody else and
perhaps the officer can answer us
tomorrow with that condition
can we say where this condition is i
can't seem to see it here yeah the
reason
there is please can i just have some
there is no such condition imposed to
this application
yeah it was imposed to the access point
yeah which was determined and as i said
following the debate we have imposed
this condition
finally chairman if you don't mind if
this report is silent in relation to
keeping the road clear but it does speak
to wheel washing so i take great comfort
in that and i will go and check it
chairman and i'll come back to you thank
you
yes it's such a great yeah
he talks about will voicing in the
section that i i believe that's what
you're referring to in the section that
i replied to the comments raised by the
highway sorry the
hey yeah the paris um so again in in in
my response i made reference to this
permission about the construction access
points
this this permission does not relate
with the does not involve any
construction access point so it would be
irrelevant to impose such condition into
this permission you wouldn't meet the
six tests
um
it's
yeah so
all i'm saying or in my response to to
the paris
um i've explained that this was included
into the permission in relation to the
access point construction access points
germany but there was one other point
and that was under condition one and i
did ask why the construction environment
management plan wasn't mentioned i mean
we we mentioned badges and bats but we
don't mention something which is
terribly important to the the residents
german and not the mammals
again it has not been included
it has not been included because it
doesn't for anna
chairman um the condition one relates to
the plans and documents submitted as
part of this application conditions
details etc that submit under
application other applications are not a
consideration for this application they
do not form of any content of condition
one
that is why documents that have been
approved under separate applications or
under discharge conditions are not
listed here because they are not
relevant to this application this list
of plans and then subsequent list of
documents relates solely to the
application we're debating tonight we
are here to discuss a relatively small
aspect to a very large development and
all the other considerations are not for
consideration or debate tonight and they
will not and cannot form part of the
conditions that we impose on any of this
application thank you chairman if i can
come back then i propose that we uh
agree the officer's recommendation and
leave me there
i've got one other speaker miss cancer
durham yeah thank you
we were in danger of going dangerously
off-piste um
i think we've established that
everything to do with the cleanliness of
the road was dealt with in the previous
application i remember both myself and
councillor fluke going into great detail
about wheel washing keeping the road
clear of mud and indeed dust and debris
during the summer months now if the road
today and over the last few days is
muddy then there's a breach in that
condition that was set in the last time
so i would hope that that breach is
being looked at so i accept the fact
that it's not part of this
but there is an extent reserve matters
uh permission that involves keeping the
roads clear and if the roads aren't
clear they're in breach of that
application
not this one
so
would would you like to
no no nothing okay all right okay
i have no idea because i've not been
driving down the road so yeah but in
principle i don't okay members we we
have had a proposal which was uh
proposed by council fluker and seconded
by
uh councillor fleming um
yes and and that is that is with the
deleted uh repetition on one of the
conditions okay so so the um
the proposal is to
uh recommend approval is that agreed
that is past then
agenda item seven uh
just bear with me a moment
members yeah no that's fine all right
thank you
yes councillor edwards i'm sorry i don't
agree i have abstained can i not be
noted
yes your abstention is noted and
actually i'll have saying as well please
well i think it's already been agreed
members so it won't it won't change a
decision but just i don't agree with
that i said no i will note your
dissentions thank you
uh any other business that the chairman
of the committee decides to urgent i
have none
members and officers i thank you for
your contributions this evening i draw
the meeting to a close of 2029
please do not engage in any further
discussion on this forum leaving the
meeting
promptly
and i bid those watching our streaming
service a very good night
and thank you
you